you know the Rex right this time in Rex
he's an actor very handsome I love them
yeah yeah I don't know if you do I do I
don't know something wrong you don't
know him okay well he used to do vine
and he had the same thing happened to
him where he was like I was trying to
hang out with my family in Hawaii and
all I could do was like what do I find
next here should I find that child and
then like make fun of the child yeah or
let and it just turns into this thing we
like wait I'm not even living and I'm
like I'm living through this app right I
have to think of captions it's bad it's
so bad it's so bad
it's pain and suffering it's a new
modern like sickness yeah it's a new
thing too it's like it's you know it's
the last 10-15 years there've always
tell you like scale back on your use of
social media and your your happiness
level will go up go up for sure a
thousand percent but when it's tied to
what you do it's your image is a part of
your visit which is weird
yeah you know and um and I just have
here's another thing about me that I
just realized and I hate this about
myself is is that I was in Seattle and I
have a friend named Josh mm-hmm
who lives there and I grew up with him
nice kid he's a friend and he gave me
this long tax about you know it's like
weird you come into town you don't call
me we should hang out but nothing I'm
like he wrote me this long thing how
good a friends were you we grew up grew
we all grew up together
but even as adults you were friends yeah
because I don't like when people
obligate me to to like hanging out
because I knew them in fourth grade like
that that shit's tiring like I'm gonna
spread my energy like well I understand
that but when you grew up with somebody
and you're friends with somebody growing
up and I know this it's because I I
turned into a comedian and then in my
head I met cooler people you don't mean
that like you know if that's in my
that's not that I must not be there
I'm being I'm trying I don't want to be
that is what I'm saying yeah I love the
guy right I do I hang out with him no
and I'm like I just like that and I I
don't know it's it's like why is my
friends only Chris D'Elia and all these
kind of people are you that way are you
similar what we're like you only want to
hang out with the cool kids who are in
no no no no I've got my like super close
friends I kind of try to I mean the only
thing I can really think of is like I
try to keep it like Leonardo DiCaprio
like I hang out my mom a lot I love her
to death I hang out with my brother and
my pair I love my family I love my
cousins right I love family yeah I have
friends that are that aren't comics but
they I'd met them in my 20s right I
didn't grew up with them and they're
more you get more options I guess when
you go out into the world right so I'm
not saying that you know like you know I
get what you're saying but what I'm
saying is is that you didn't want to
take it's not that it's like it's like
no it's it's I'm gonna say something I
took a picture you want to post that
that's another thing I don't post like
photos of like if you know if it's not
cool people Oh girls I know I I'm
admitting it I'm admitting it yes it's
true I see yeah and I know you know what
and I'm being I'm being I'm admitting it
I hate that about myself I want to
change that about myself
and I'm throwing it out there I'm
blushing I know you can't tell when I'm
Asian right but I am blushing you got to
drink some alcohol right now yeah and I
don't like that about myself and I'm
that's why I'm throwing it out there
because I want to change I really saw
your next post has to be with George
never I would like yeah George and I
yeah if it was your birthday and I took
a photo I wouldn't post it but can I
defend myself I don't post a lot true I
poke post once a month
sure so the one that I had do post has
to be one that I believe in it's got to
be but I believe in you
you gotta believe in it it's gonna be
funny yeah I mean it's gotta be a bunch
of different factors I would say in
Bossier to feel bad no yeah me there's
not you don't have yes are you kidding
me like just being who you guys are
it is very difficult to navigate and
like man have people manage their
expectations of you right so it's like
you want to be able to be this performer
and this kind person and not be a dick
but to be able to be able to make
everyone happy is damn near impossible
you want to preserve a little bit for
yourself you know and that's a lot of
energy to accommodate a lot of people
here's another thing you know when I'm
on the road if Josh is listening I I did
press Friday morning
kalila her niece her best friend are
also there
right so I'm juggling they I have to do
five shows noon it's Josh's fault
[ __ ] let's go he said that long text
message and already I wanted to send
back so [ __ ] funny we're not editing
Josh we can't know right when this goes
up I'm commenting
[Laughter]
[Music]